kind of any apologies were asked to note
the committee membership for this
Municipal year is that agreed
thank you and the terms of reference
which you will have added us to have a
look at and the minutes of the meeting
on the 20th of February are there any
questions or comments arising from those
minutes
for anybody who was here no okay chair
can I just make a point of clarification
just on the description of the corporate
director it says corporate direct people
it should say corporate director
strategy and resources said can we just
take that
um Amendment please thank you thank you
Angela uh I've not been notified of any
questions from the public Alex have you
received anything later uh no no no
thank you in that case we will move on
to the workforce update which we've had
a sort of uh grilling and jewelry on
this so
okay thanks chair
um as you can see the we've presented a
slightly refreshed Workforce update in
the pack this time
um and it's so it concentrates on
information hopefully that provides you
with some assurance that um
from a HR service perspective where
supporting us to be a great employer
um we're also updating the people
strategy
um which is framed around the four
pillars and I think it's important
to just make sure that in everything
that we do we remind ourselves of what
those
um four key areas are in the people
strategy and so they're included in the
visuals um which you'll see on page two
of the refreshed Workforce update
so there's some key Workforce metrics
that we've included this time
um which you'll find on page three and
this is around the numbers of occupied
posts in the council I think the data is
is there
it tells us that at the moment we've got
um 2400 employees working with us in
that's our head count and they work in
an equivalent of
1933 full-time positions
um we've got a range of employment
um schemes in place for varied working
patterns which allow our Workforce to
um as I say work in those um different
working patterns and enjoy a work-life
balance so those individual
circumstances could relate to
um working in a job share Arrangement
part-time for example and flexible
retirement roles or condensed working
patterns so we have a range of different
working Arrangements that hopefully will
be attractive to people who want to work
with us the largest
um provision of occupied posts in the
next page on page
for as you can see we've got a table in
there which then drills into the number
of employees per grade and this shows us
where the concentration of employees are
I think it's a really good visual we're
not going to share this with you every
time unless you absolutely want us to
but it just gives you an idea of where
the um the salary budget is is kind of
used in in that space
I think if we go then into page
um five
we're then into the agency spend now I'm
not going to spend too much time on this
because we have a report on the agenda
on agency spend we take a regular report
through to employment committee
um that talks us talks us through all of
the um the challenges and the
opportunities that we've got in in this
space and I think you know it is very
much all about how we enable us to
recruit and retain great people
um as one of our people's strategy
Ambitions so I'm not going to spend too
much time because as I say we have a
report on the agenda and we can spend
the time perhaps on in that space then
so I think the next bit of information
I'll just
um draw out is where we have as we all
know we've achieved the real living wage
which is an amazing achievement
I think it allows us to promote that we
are reliving wage employer we are now a
full member of the greater Manchester
employment Charter
um which is
um it's all about how we can Elevate
employment standards I guess across
um the the conurbation
um so we've had supported status for a
number of years as I say we've just
applied for and been successful in in
attaining member status because we now
meet the criteria across the seven
characteristics that they are um saying
is is about good employment which is all
around secure work pay recruitment
health and well-being flexibility which
I've kind of described earlier how we
manage our people and how we engage with
our Workforce
so I think having that member status it
will be a really good employment kite
Mark for us and we're also going to use
it to Brand all of our recruitment
literature and it's going to flow
through all of our campaigns and
advertisements
so I've also included in the information
some information on turnover it's a
rolling 12-month figure
um I think it's fair to say that the
turnover has fluctuated a little bit
over the last couple of years I think we
all we've we've talked here before I
think around the impact of covid and
we've had the national sort of great
resignation for example where people
have chosen to make life-changing
decisions and that has impacted across
um you know the workforce on a national
scale
so our Workforce estate a turnover sorry
has stabilized now 12.93 in March
um so that's there is a visual for you
all to see the Journey of the turnover
figures across
um the um from 2000 2021 to to current
date
we've also got a visual in there now on
thickness and this is the rolling 12
month figure for sickness absence
um we report it by a percentage of total
available time lost sickness absence
again you can see the fluctuation
um there in the um in the report
um it's
fair to say it's probably stabilized a
little bit now it's it's kind of peaked
and it's now um at the end of the
financial year it's it's at 4.5 I think
again this is an area where from a HR
service perspective I know the team are
working closely with managers to manage
um the impact of sickness absence
um over the um the period and to seek um
return to work as speedily as as
possible if that is you know if that is
is going to be um achievable
so I think also in the report this time
I've also included some recent changes
to some of the policy initiatives just
so you can see flavor of some of the
areas of work that the team are working
on
um there's a there's a vast array of
employment benefits
um again it's all in the um HR and
learning web pages
um if you wanted to have a scoot around
and see what's what's in in there this
is just a snapshot really of some of the
um the employment benefits that we've
got in place at the moment
they've also added in there some
information around our apprenticeship
schemes again this is an area where
we're really passionate about recruiting
people into roles within Trafford and
also upskilling because because
apprenticeships are also a way of
upskilling the The Wider Workforce and
using the apprenticeship Levy as a as a
um a real opportunity
um to bring in sort of learning
um and and you know I think from The
Narrative that's there we've also used
it to
um
encourage
individuals in the organization to for
example undertake Social Work degree
apprenticeship so again there's lots of
information on our Learning and
Development offer an official on the
apprenticeship
um information too
so I think the only other thing I mean
Richard's done a really great update
previously around the health and safety
initiative around your safety your
well-being so again
um I think there's a lot of really great
work going on in that space to enable
our workflow Workforce to feel safe
um in in in work and to ensure that you
know we're doing all we can to support
our Workforce to bring their best selves
to work by offering them a really
comprehensive health and safety and
well-being offer
um I think we've already mentioned we
provide some quite a few
services to schools so that's in in on
page 12 and then I think the only other
thing I will mention is we have
undertaken a review of our hybrid
working Arrangements
um which have been in place since we all
returned back to what was what what we
thought was The New Normal which is now
probably the old normal and so hybrid
working has um probably been in place
for a couple of years now so we've taken
some feedback from managers in the
organization and colleagues at our
engagement events and on the back of
that feedback hybrid working is very
much here to stay in Trafford we just
need to perhaps do some
um slight variations and slight tweets
to um the policy arrangements and then
we'll be rolling that back out to
managers with with you know the guidance
is already there we're just gonna
tighten up the guidance where where it
needs to be tightened up so that there
is very much a focus on ensuring that
service provision is is absolutely at
the core and at the heart of
um you know the the way that we deliver
we we operate within the hybrid working
framework
so I'm going to stop there because I
think you know there's there's a lot of
information in the detail of the update
and and just take questions or comments
[Music]
um thanks for the new layout of the
report I think it's great sorry Council
home before Gossel and corn Brook Ward
and thanks to new layout I think it's
absolutely great I was just wondering if
you'd be able to add in um for next time
basically
it's very similar to slide three but the
breakdown of um vacancies and unoccupied
posts per Department as well and just so
we can see
which areas are overall
um over indexing or which areas are
doing really well with with that yeah
yeah well we'll take that away and we'll
have a look at adding some more data
around
what the vacancy position looks like
within
um directorates
thank you uh two questions if that's all
right chair
um firstly just on the real living wage
uh status so last time uh employee
employment committee I asked about
Trafford Leisure and what progress they
were making and I suppose the question
this time is again what progress the
traffic Leisure making towards real
living wage accreditation and how can we
as a partner facilitate and encourage
that
um the second question
um is on elections which is in the
report but you didn't touch on there I
just wanted to say a massive thank you
firstly to everybody who works on
elections because I think across the
board staff are first-rate whether it's
at the counter at the polling station so
in relation to voter ID which councilor
Acton touched on before and and exposed
The Wider experience of our staff at
elections was an exit survey handed out
uh to polling station staff and to count
staff this year just to trap that uh
experience and to build and to build on
it in terms of our training offer going
forward
okay thank you very good questions thank
you so much so in terms of Trafford I am
delighted to report that Trafford
Leisure are now on their journey to
becoming a real living wage employer and
we
um expect to be able to enact those
decisions and
very very quickly and so we had
anticipated ring and Trafford Leisure
online in the next 12 months but we've
been able to bring that forward and we
are working with Trafford ledgers to do
that in this financial year
um in response to your second question
thank you so much for recognizing the
staff involved and really appreciate
that and we didn't survey staff
um
good suggestion maybe for future but we
definitely didn't do it this time but we
have taken feedback from colleagues
um verbal feedback who
um all commented from the perspective of
count staff and those involved in the
count of the training that we undertalk
in advance of the election this year
really helped them understand the role
and more effectively and they found the
process this year
um much more streamlined in terms of
polling station staff we didn't
um as I say hand out a questionnaire but
we did get some available feedback of
which nothing to note from a negative
perspective other than the usual it's a
very long day
um and and we know that and going into
it we do have
a really loyal base of Staff who tend to
be our polling station staff and our
account staff and our postal code staff
every year and and we are hoping that
they will be back with us next May and
but we'll take on board that comment
because it may be worth
um looking into some sort of exit poll
next time thank you
counselor
I want to understand
you should
Tuesday the first
at least
two days before 3 days and then you come
back at least two days a week relaxing
in a crucible the castle yeah
I understand you might be graduate so
many different things
responsibility do we have any diversity
and institution that matters such as how
many female and stuff in our overall
particular and especially in the senior
management level and secondly do we have
anything about acting Immunology
problems
yeah in the common World these are the
largest public in Odyssey our children
yeah thank you thanks very much for your
questions in terms of the ratio haven't
got the exact ratio of numbers at the
moment and we're doing as I say a piece
of work to review the hybrid working
arrangement so I can get that for you
um I think it's very much around
what we've tried to do is whilst we want
services to feel empowered to
um and enable hybrid working to be in
place for those Services it's very much
about what's one service working
Arrangements is going to be very
different to another service working
arrangement so it's all about
and ensuring that you know from a
service provision perspective so long as
the services are provided and there's no
impact on service provision it's very
much around how Services want to make
hybrid working work for those
individuals who work in those Services
bearing in mind that there will be a
very you know diverse range of
individuals where some people don't want
to work in hybrid working style for
example and what we're finding is that
very much people want actually to to
come back into an office environment and
I think what we're finding is that it is
very much starting to feel a lot more
like you know sort of the the norm pre
the introduction of hybrid working
however it is there as an option
um very much for the organization to to
take advantage of so I can get you some
information around sort of the ratios
um so in as long as across the the
working week the surfaces that needed to
to work in that way are covered and
there will be some services that hybrid
working will not work for and I think we
have to accept that as I said we also
have to accept there isn't going to be a
one-size-fits-all approach either so it
is a complex sort of set of
circumstances we are a complex
organization and we have to accept that
too so the review that we've done has
sought to insofar as is possible and
we'd all want this wouldn't we we'd all
want to have a consistent approach
across the piece but that probably isn't
going to be the case
um
so hopefully I've answered your question
around the the hybrid working style and
I will bring you some further
information on that
I think in terms of the second question
then um the staff diversity question yes
absolutely we do have some information
that we publish
um on our open data which is on the
workforce facts and figures we've got a
snapshot as at the 31st of March 2023
it's on our Council website and I can
send you all the link and to that
information
um obviously as a public sector
organization we have to provide this
this information
um and we've tried so hard as well to to
get more information from our Workforce
in in the sort of the diversity Arena
but you know we are struggling some
people just don't want to tell us and
for example if they are um they um
identify as disabled for example so now
what I can tell you though is that
um 75 of our Workforce is female and 25
of our Workforce is male and females
would are in the top five percent of
salary so 61 of our females are in the
top five percent of salaries
um and employees who self-certify is
having a disabled in the top five
percent of salaries is is in the
percentage of 4.87 and all of this data
is on our website so I can send you the
um the link with the minutes from from
the meeting so you can have a look at
some of that information that's that's
shared there
I think well what I'd also say is we've
done some work
um most recently with our Trade union
colleagues as well
um to try to encourage our Workforce to
provide more more meaningful data
um we're always on that Journey we're
always wanting to work with our managers
with our Workforce
um to as I say to encourage them to to
provide us with that information because
in unless we know we can't then sort of
think about the impact of of what
they're telling us so it is really
um you know a an ongoing and very open
piece of work that we are still trying
to um
enable us to to get that more meaningful
data and so absolutely it's it's a it's
a really good question and I probably
should have covered that in the update
so I think for the update next time as
well we'll we'll include some of that
data
um for you
yeah yeah
absolutely absolutely so for example you
know we've only got um of those
individuals who have provided us with
their data
um we're saying that we've got 12.55 of
employees from ethnic ethnically diverse
communities in the whole Workforce
um so which is a really small number so
absolutely you know that is one of my
top priorities really working very
closely with our
um equalities
um
team lead
um using the Census Data to as well
direct sort of where our attention needs
to be
um so that we can sort of encourage and
support communities linked again to some
of the things that we've talked about
our community recruitment events
absolutely you know it is so important
for our Workforce to be representative
of the communities that we serve
um so it is very much in terms of a
people strategy ambition it is very much
in in the top top priority
yeah
how many times
yes 100
um
absolutely
emotions uh all this all the style the
current
confidence
but we haven't mentioned the core
working with us
yes we do that's one of the the kind of
where I mentioned earlier with
tightening up on that so we're going to
be very clear around the core working
array core working hours so I think you
know there is an expectation that's core
working hours will be covered Monday to
Sunday if obviously we have staffy work
kind of you know weekend working as well
but Monday to Friday for sure we will
need to we will
um ensure that there are
there is cover there is availability I
think it's access and availability of of
the workforce over core working hours
which is sort of seven till seven
yeah so just to give you that
reassurance I suppose that in the the
the the model for hybrid working there
is still going to be an expectation that
the workforce the availability will be
across core working time
okay councilor Leicester
thank you Mike my question follows on
from that actually
um you mentioned that we thought
obviously with hybrid working not all
roles lend themselves to that so it's
particularly operational roles that it's
not feasible but there's a real danger
then that you create an inequality in
the workforce of a group of Staff who
can who are able to work from home and
have got that increased flexibility to
another and another group of Staff who
haven't got that flexibility how can we
make sure that we sort of support those
staff who don't have those opportunities
to in terms of ensuring a good work life
balance
I think I think again it's about how
that that group of staff that Core group
of Staff who perhaps don't have access
to work in hybrid working but they work
in a more
regimented or rigid day so they work
kind of core hours I guess so they they
have a working pattern with um Flex
obviously breaks in between but it's
about you know recognizing that they're
they're working time is is is that
working time and that there isn't then
the ability perhaps to work in a more
flexible way but then that does attract
sort of extra
um payment for example if they do need
to work in it in a sort of additional
hours and I think it's the point I made
earlier as well whereby you know when
we're not going to probably get to that
place where we accept that there is
going to be a one-size-fits-all approach
I think there is a recognition that for
some roles at the moment we do need
um certain roles to work in a bit more
of a structured way but in in in
allowing those roles to to work in in
that way it's also recognizing that they
are very much you know that they have a
start time time out so of you know kind
of for
um lunch and and a very clear finish
time as well
um whereas I think you know if you're
working in a hybrid way you don't get
that you very much are I suppose in in
what you have more control over your
working time but you do then vary your
hours slightly differently and probably
not describing that very well but I
suppose it's just a recognition that at
the moment we haven't you know we have
to accept that that is
um you know a a situation that we have
within our organization and we're no
different you know obviously we're all
grappling with the you know the the pro
the pros the benefits of this particular
way of working as opposed to you know we
also recognize that they're asked for
some roles that we we can't
enable that sort of way of working to to
to work but that's not to say that you
know we we when we're not completely
ruling it out either it's just that at
this point in time it's probably not not
there
um
and it's a choice as well I guess isn't
it it's a choice that people make around
how they want to
um spend their working time
I suppose that then but I was thinking
of maybe other flexibilities that could
be made available to people who who were
set hours you know maybe there were a
shift that they have to work at set
hours and they have to be present
because it's a practical job that they
have to be on site for but just an
example you know say you had a child who
wasn't very well an older child who's
capable looking after themselves they're
off sick and you could say actually is
it all right if I work from home today
and it would be fine because that person
can fully complete their role but
somebody in another role would have to
take care as leave to you there's sort
of there's a loss of flexibility there
isn't there and just finding the way
that you can incorporate it and that's
that's so important so it is just
ensuring that where we do have you know
the ability to flex Our advice and and
guidance and we do have a myriadiff
family friendly employment policy so
where we we have got that ability then
yes absolutely it goes without saying
that we would enable that where we can
um as as a you know kind of an
organization it's it is very much in our
interest to
um enable the working experience to be
to be a great one and ideally you know
as fair and Equitable as it is it
possibly can be so yes absolutely Jane
just just to answer and give you that
sort of reassurance where we can then
yes that that would absolutely be the
case but thanks for your question it's
really really good one really good
question
thank you Angela we're going to now move
on to agency Sprint for quarter four
[Music]
I'm going to um talk you through the
agency spend report and some of the
headline figures and then we'll go into
a bit more detail
um with each directorate and so
we're looking at quarter four which was
a January to March this year
um and you'll see the overall spending
section three and and also in appendix
one you'll see and the spend with read
and that's all broken down and with
directorates enroll with the the overall
spend and the overall spend in the
quarter was one million 625 439
and it's important to say that the
agency costs for the quarter have been
fully met from all existing Staffing
budgets
and it has actually decreased from the
previous quarter and but it does remain
static when we compare that spend with
the same quarter last year and it was
quite a similar spend
um last year
and we do have uh as Angela's mentioned
a robust vacancy clearance process in
place so and if managers do require an
agency worker for whatever reason it
goes through and an approval process and
it comes to my team and for approval
before an audit can be placed
and I think we do need to recognize that
there's there's always going to be times
where we will need
um agency workers and usually short-term
in nature and it's where we really need
an immediate resource in need you know
we're not able to to wait the time for a
role to be advertised and recruited to
and that could be for a number of
reasons and one of them is is covering
day-to-day absences and or if we need
temporary support and to meet the
critical gaps in a particular service
and or also if we need specialist skills
in the organization and to come in
quickly so and we've done that recently
with some it roles and the um for
example cyber security and
um M365 there's been some roles there
that we've needed to Resource and
quickly and we needed the The Specialist
skills
so I'll move through now to and each
directorate and first of all and
children's services so the agency
spending Children's Services was 967 933
and in children's services majority is
um on social workers level three social
workers where we need experienced social
workers to come in and pick up those
more complex cases
and we have a GM collaborative contract
with Reed there are managed service
provider and so they are our first point
of call and to
um Place orders where we have a resource
in need and but we also have our own
social worker framework and within
Trafford where we've got other
um suppliers that are not on the read
contract that we can go to and if we're
struggling or if we just struggle into
Supply
and so you will see that there is spends
and you know between read and also the
social worker framework
and during the quarter we had 77 active
assignments in children's services
and you will um see that the um the
majority of spend is those level three
social worker roles
um
so mainly the the interim Staffing need
is to cover staff in resource gaps and
that's usually coverings common or
maternity leave or sickness absence and
we often do recruiting agency worker if
we'll we're recruiting to the post so
whilst there's a gap in getting those
pre-employment clearances in
and there are National challenges really
you know and linked to um Social Work
Recruitment and this is why we need to
have an a good
um process in place to be able to get an
agency social workers and to work at
Trafford
we work in um partnership with the
Strategic lead in children's services
and we've implemented a really good
recruitment strategy we have rolling
adverts
um and we're doing really well at the
moment actually in terms of covering our
core vacancies and within the service
and Angela mentioned before as well and
we're also working towards the um GM
pledge or Northwest pledge and to ensure
that we pay all our social workers
consistently and across GM and we're
hoping for a September launch for that
because at the moment there are um
disparities you know one
um Council might agree to pay more than
another and then we're left in a
competition
um with our sort of local authorities
we do a lot of work and in terms of
growing our own and to make sure that we
have and social workers that are are
trained and and we can retain so there's
some information there about the
um asye program so that's where newly
qualified social workers and are
supported within services
we have social work and students come in
on Final placements and then and we can
look to offer them interviews for any
vacancies that we have
and we also have a social worker
apprenticeship program so and we have a
lot of our existing staff who
um are on Career Pathways to be a social
worker and we support and the social
work apprenticeship and career
progression between level two and level
three
so that was children's I'll move on to
Adult Services now and again the the
spend is mainly on social care and
social workers and support workers so
spend this quarter in Adult Services was
264 330 and it was all via read and our
umbrella agency there was no other um
contract spend there and the largest
spend was on an interim qualified social
worker roles and and that has decreased
in this quarter from the last quarter
we also have quite a lot of spend
um for support workers which is at Ascot
house and our supported living service
and the spend on this quarter and in for
support workers was 92 372.
and
I just had it wasn't all support workers
there were some and Deputy managers at
Ascot house that we um recruited where
we needed some um quick support into the
service and again
um Adult Services you know similar to
Children's we have our Trafford Learning
Academy where we're looking at
recruiting and growing and retraining
and our staff so that they're going to
be you know our adult social care
Workforce of the future
and we also
um have agreed to pay a market
supplement to um our adult social
workers and we also have a market
supplement for children so that helps in
the the Recruitment and when we compare
ourselves to other authorities and in
terms of what salary and rates that
we're offering we want to remain
competitive
um across GM in the social worker Market
um and Japanese in children's we have
also supported
um newly qualified and social workers we
have a cohort Social Work students and
and also the social worker degree
apprenticeship
sorry in adults
and I'll move over now to legal and
government governance and the spending
legal in government governance in the
quarter was 158 418 and and that has
decreased compared to the last quarter
and larger spend is always on on legal
and solicitors qualified solicitors and
and you know we do struggle to to
recruit to those roles and on a
permanent basis because we're in
competition with the private sector
private legal roles and pay a lot more
than what the council can so that's
where we've got to look at our over
overall package and what we can offer as
a total reward
and moving on to finance and systems and
spend was relatively
um low in finance and systems of 23 958
and just a couple of roles really that
we're recruiting to in that area and in
terms of a finance manager and also and
some staff to support the role out of
Windows 365.
and in place again small amount of spend
4184 and and that was for um English for
speakers of other languages and assessor
roles and so that's linking in um with
the the funds that we have to support
Ukraine and and
um
and Hong Kong Nationals too
in strategy and resources and the spend
was 16 857 and and that's really been on
a range of roles and some roles catering
roles for the terrorists here at the
Town Hall and some roles in
Communications and application support
officer
so as I said the total spend and does
remain static when compared to the the
previous quarter last year and you'll
see on um in section four that's how we
compare across GM and and yeah we I
think we're about fifth out of the the
11 councils in terms of our spend and
you can see that the breakdown of the
spend there in table two
and then finally just
um just to bring you make you aware of
the consultant spend and so this is
where we um take on and self-employed
Consultants to do and various pieces of
bespoke pieces of work so the the not
through the um the agency framework at
all and the spend is being totally in
children's and in the quarter it was 19
345 and and they are there's four
Consultants that are
um doing particular pieces work such as
one is the independent chair of the
senboard and we've also got a consultant
who is reviewing and safeguarding
processes and practice so they'll be
brought in for a set piece of work for a
period of time
so to conclude an agency and consultancy
spend will and be monitored on a regular
basis we we get all the figures each
month and we'll present this to
employment committee every quarter
I'm happy to take any questions
thank you and thank you for that report
there so my question is about the
Northwest pledge and uh if I'm listening
right to what was said earlier it sounds
like we could very well be considering
market uplifts for social workers in
September
um so how confident are we that we're on
track for that September launch because
that work is really important because
once September Comes or we do
potentially approve a market uplift so
it wouldn't work with that in that
situation again as we were last year
where it's Stockport there's Manchester
do theirs we're back here this time next
year I appreciate that we're one
in that great to watch the work but
how confident are we of that launch
um I think we are pretty confident of
that launch date being in September
there's been an awful lot of work done
to um and we
um we know that we are paying too much
at the moment
um as an hourly rate you know we're
paying more in GM than perhaps in London
and so you know we know we've got to
take control of those rates and and
agree across the board and and I think
we're nearly there we do have agreed
rates at the moment that we
um you know stick to as a whole and
Trafford are very good at sticking to
those agree greed rates and it would
only be
um if there was a real need and to pay
more for whatever reason we would
consider that for example
um a social worker and that is mental
health approved and qualified we might
look to and you know pay a little bit
more per hour for those
um but yeah I think we're at the stage
now where we do know and I mean the
rates were go up at all that there'll be
static we can't possibly increase them
anymore and we pay around 30 pounds an
hour for a social worker in adults and
35 for a social worker in children's and
so you know we really need to to ensure
that we can stick to those rates and
all my HR colleagues and resourcing
colleagues in GM you know we're all
wanting that appetite because we don't
want to be competing with each other's
um agency workers and we don't want one
to move from us to go to Stockport to
get two pound more you know an hour so
um I think we're pretty um ready now for
for this pledge to come in
councilor Leicester
um I want to as you were talking about
one of the issues with that was um
amounts was around the funding for home
to Ukraine funds for the esol set
lessons
um are they is that is that money going
to continue is that uh at the moment as
things stand because it also being used
for the Asylum Seekers as well isn't
that I think that ties in with them
so and I just want to chat that that
wasn't going to stop
I was going to say I haven't got an
answer for that particular question but
I know my colleague SATs your left may
very well be able to answer that one I
want to come in on the back of the GM
pledge and so we do have some money
remaining in our allocation for aim
supporting Ukraine Nationals and we will
continue to use that until until the
funding dries up we're not aware of any
additional funding at this stage but
that can change and very quickly
Angela all I was going to say is just
hot off the press there has been slight
slippage with the September Day for
implementation of the greater Manchester
pledge it's now been pushed back to
October so I'll keep the committee
informed if there's any further
um delays to that but just to add um to
what Cal said I think there is a
commitment across the local Authority
conurbation the 10 greater Manchester
authorities to
um work within those pay rates and the
protocols of the greater Manchester
pledge will bring a report back here
um to the next employment committee
which will kind of go into a little bit
more detail
um and I think it's it's just so
important isn't it that we do get that
consistency of pay rates and that
consistency of application across our
um statistics our greater Manchester
neighbors
um to enable us to to retain
um good people as well so just just a
slight update for for the committee
as I say very much hot off the press
today
councilor Jones
thanks
um just as I'm new to Committee just
some kind of background for me so we're
talking about agency workers here so if
we kind of look at two sets of agency
Works which are kind of quite a lot of
the money for them level three social
workers how many of those or What
proportion of those are agency workers
compared to who are staff within traffic
themselves and on the legal staff which
you'd have said do you have trouble
actually recruiting
um how many of those are kind of
In-House and how many are agency and are
they short-term the legal staff are they
like short-term contracts
to get that information for you um
councilor Jones if that's okay it gives
me a bit of background yeah absolutely
and any any ask you know I'm happy to
spend some time just kind of giving you
um background information so let's set
something up offline thank you okay
thanks no further questions now we'll go
on to the reports on exemptions to the
sickness policy which is a verbal update
and that's with um Beverly I'm going to
bring Beverly Norton into to do this one
counselor
all right
thank you very much good afternoon
um okay so I'm giving a verbal update on
our occupational sick pay exceptions
report
um just for a bit of background for for
new attendees
um in terms of what the OSP exceptions
are Trafford offer an already very
generous occupational sick pay scheme to
its employees of up to three months full
pay in three months half pay if an
individual is absent due to long-term
sickness absence
in addition to that we also have a
discretionary opportunity for employees
to request to be considered to have
their pay extended beyond that generous
OSP
um sick pay scheme where there are
exceptional circumstances which may
exist for that particular individual
so I'm delighted to be able to report to
you on both quarter three which is
September 22 to December 22 and also
quarter four which is January 23 to
March 2023 and obviously bring you
completely up to date at this committee
meeting
so during quarter three September to
December 22 we received eight exception
requests in total spanning four of our
six directorates of the eight exception
requests received seven were approved
one was withdrawn as it was no longer
required
to give you a flavor for the predominant
reasons for the requests
um the the sort of
top reasons relate to cancer and also to
Long covered
and I can report that six of the seven
exception requests have now been
resolved either those individuals have
been supported to successfully return
back into their role or alternatively to
access their pension via the ill health
retirement scheme
for quarter four which is January to
March 2023
in total we received 11 exception
requests
across four of our directorates I can
confirm that all of those 11 requests
were approved and again the main reasons
relate to cancer and neurological
conditions
I can report that five of the 11
requests have been supported now to
either return to work or indeed to
access their pension via ill health
retirement
what we are seeing are more complex
multiple health conditions coming
through and we are seeing an increase in
the number of requests received in
quarter two were reported on five and we
are providing a great deal of support to
managers in terms of managing the
challenging conditions and that they're
seeing amongst their staff and obviously
providing the financial support wherever
we can to those individuals that meet
the criteria thank you having to take
any questions thanks I've not been
notified of any urgent business so call
the meeting closed and thank you for
your attendance